well what can you tell us about you're
the first person to ever ask me yeah and
I do have some news that nobody else
knows the reason being I only got this
news what day is today what's today
Friday no it's so we got this I got an
email on Wednesday okay let me tell you
what's happening to me next week I have
to leave here on Sunday but which I
don't want to I would love to stifle to
see more of this it's amazing on
Wednesday I go to New York for there's a
Comic Con in New York not for Game of
Thrones for something else and then on
Saturday I get on a plane from New York
back to Ireland I run into my house for
20 minutes say hello to my family
and then I get in a car and I go
straight up to Belfast where we are
having the first do you call a table
read a read-through non-temporary
we have the first table read on Sunday
of the of three episodes on on Sunday
and then on Monday we read the next
three and that's so that's Monday then
we have then we rehearse for the rest of
that week with their two of the
directors there's three directors for
the final six and then we start filming
I think officially it's either the 16th
or the 19th of October so what's that
three weeks time three three three weeks
time we start
and that's that's real news that's real
news now I have to check with HBO if I
could tell you so that that's proper its
proper new yeah it's a note so nobody
else knows that that's good news though
it's very good news yeah absolutely
and speaking about BBA the last season
yeah
would you rather die in a spectacular
way will being about me dying your
character better than why don't you ask
why don't you ask what I will do when
I'm sitting on the throne what you asked
that question but would you rather die a
memorable death or to be just in the
last frame of the last episode of the
last season of Game of Thrones I think I
think what should happen is we should
take the throne when I'm finally king
yeah and bring it over to Dorne the wine
is really good it's like Tuscan wine
that's beautiful
it's like Tuscany well and myself and
maybe
missandei could retire quietly it's a
Dorne
what if I'm right if I get I'll get in
terrible trouble if I say I think it's
this / and they go you idiot you told
them I don't know what I didn't know all
right just a guess cuz I got cuz I got
in trouble before cuz there last year I
got in trouble and because somebody
asked me when is the new season coming
it's going to be late and I said I think
it's gonna be around July and I got
phone calls and Twitter went mad they
said a verse is it's coming out in July
not my on Iran our Christ B and the
reason I guessed because we started
three months later we started filming
three months later we finished three
months later and I went it's probably
gonna come out three months later but
the problem was always right and they
hadn't announced the date so I kind of
struggled so I'm not guessing I'm not
saying no way
so when we'll be able to to watch the
eighth season of Game of Thrones no just
because it were a stick I have it on a
USB there's one for everybody look you
know when well I mean if you have to
think about this it's going to be a huge
season
and there's various rumors about when
we're stopping and they're not quite
sure yet because of the size of the
season but it's going to be summer next
year before we finish and it's for six
episodes so these as far as I know all
the episodes are gonna be really long
that to the best of my knowledge um some
people are saying feature length but uh
but we're spending a lot longer shooting
six than we have with shooting ten so
this year so so that's gonna make things
go later so if it goes to the end of
summer and with the amount of
post-production with with obviously with
computer stuff and and everything else
it's it's very unlikely you're gonna see
it next year I mean you could but it
would look [ __ ] so to make it look as
beautiful as we've made a look in the
past it's looking incredible we don't
have a date but it's increasingly
looking like it's going to be 2019 but
we haven't been told I'm I haven't even
been given we're doing this script
reading on tomorrow one week and I still
haven't been given the script there I'm
getting them I think on Monday or
Tuesday I'm going to have the Newlands
on Monday and Tuesday whew hey everybody
thank the Lord of Light for sir DuBose
because he just explained exactly what's
gonna be happening with season 8 what
their timeline is what the episode
schedule is going to be it sort of backs
up the claim that the episodes will be
vastly longer than before remember 15
million dollars per episode so I'll
explain would all that stuff he just
said means because a little bit if it
was tongue-in-cheek so if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything
we'll be doing Game of Thrones videos
until season 8 gets here and they'll be
giveaway stuff at the end of the video
too so this interview actually happened
a couple days ago from the day that I'm
posting this but he basically says the
next Sunday he's going to be getting the
first three scripts they'll be doing the
table read with all of the actors like
they'll all be sitting in a giant room
going through the first three episodes
then a little while after that that
following Monday they'll do the same
thing with the final three episodes and
then a couple weeks after that they'll
actually start filming so that's
actually happening right now he pens
their official start date to where like
everybody is standing on set together
cameras are rolling around octo
/ 17th give or take a little bit in the
finish day probably being at the
beginning of the summer which would be
late June so when he talks about how it
might take till 2019 to get the episodes
out he's talking about post-production
because this year it took him about five
months to turn things around just for a
reference Emilia Clarke wrapped season
seven around February 3rd they
officially wrapped everything else just
a little while after that so it took him
about five months to do post-production
for all seven episodes presumably they
finished the seventh one as the first
one was airing so because he says that
they're filming way more footage for six
episodes than they've ever done for ten
episodes in previous seasons they're
spending fifteen million dollars and
there's some production challenges that
also slows things down a little bit it
sounds like post-production is gonna
stretch a couple more months than it
normally would which you know means that
they might be able to squeeze it out by
the end of 2018 really the holdup I
think from a CG perspective is just
having three dragons in every single
episode or almost every single episode
like think of episode four in episode
six where you had a lot of dragon action
the camera was on the dragon for a long
period of time facial replacement like
when they did the big Aria Brienne fight
they had to swap her face with the stunt
doubles face that takes a little bit
longer in a really big hardhome Battle
of the bastard style episodes where you
have giant wide crowd shots and even
though Davos didn't say it Nikolaj
coster-waldau in a separate interview
talked about how they can't rely on
their second and third filming units as
much so a lot of times in previous
seasons you'd have the dragon unit or
you'd have the wolf unit filming in
completely different parts of the world
simultaneously for scenes in the same
episode so it meant that they could film
episodes twice as fast especially when
they had three units going it was even a
fourth unit called the white Walker unit
during season six so the more film units
they have shooting scenes simultaneously
the quicker they get things out they
can't do that as much this season
because for the most part everybody's in
the same place you have everybody
converging on Winterfell and then you
have a couple people down in King's
Landing for at least most of the season
remains to be seen whether or not Cersei
is going to end season 8 down at King's
Landing but I think that would be
fitting that's a little
speculation though her life feels like
it's been so tied up in the game of
Thrones in the quest for the iron throne
for so long it would just make a lot
more sense that her story ends at the
iron throne so I'm not expecting her to
just hightail it all the way up to
Winterfell to where everyone else is
there was also a funny nod to some stuff
that was happening during season seven
that people were speculating on between
Davos and myths and I because he got
really funny with her he would ask her
weird questions like is he hitting on
her what is going on it's almost like
he's trying to drum up some chemistry
with her or something a Sunday of naath
but I don't think that that was the way
that it was written I think that was
just liam Cunningham trying to be
charming in the saint-like he just has a
way with people he's a very charming
person when he's not telling everyone
that they're royally screwed what if
someone takes the boat then left [ __ ]
that story but I do like his idea of him
surviving with Miss and I and taking the
Iron Throne down to the beaches of Dorne
just a lounge around and drink their
fine wine for the rest of his life so I
guess that would mean that they'd have
to unsink Dorne from the sea because as
of right now I think the producers are
just hoping that you forget about Doran
altogether
like you know that was a storyline that
didn't work out the way we wanted to
maybe you just forget about it and focus
on what's going up way near Winterfell
and the army of the Dead but I think
what'll happen is is once they start
filming they'll actually have a better
idea of how much longer it's going to
take them to finish and they can get
stuff into post-production if it does
look like it'll definitely spill into
2019 then I think that HBO will probably
try to do some special promotional stuff
next year in addition to the big live
concert event that they're doing so that
they can just throw fans a bone like
okay you know we understand that you're
waiting a long time but we're gonna give
you some new form of Game of Thrones but
the cool thing is is that the game of
thrones composer
that's doing the live concert has a
couple months break that starts at the
beginning of the summer meaning that
that's when he'll probably start scoring
the final episodes I think they're cut
off for 2018 we'll be like if they could
finish all the episodes and start
posting them by the end of November so
that they finish airing episode six
before the end of December then I think
we could see it during 2018 otherwise I
think that they would hold it for at
least
you areare March you don't see a whole
lot of TV series starting in February
but the other thing that's sort of
bridging the gap between season 7 season
8 is Westworld season 2 which will
probably premiere at the beginning of
the summer if not the late spring so
that's May June so I'll talk a little
bit more about Westworld season 2 when
they released the first teaser but if
you have any specific bonus video
requests just leave them in the comments
below there are a couple new cast
members that they announced they're
looking for so if you guys want me to do
a cast breakdown just let me know in the
comments below there's a Star Wars
trailer that's dropping tomorrow so I
have some new Rick and Morty coming in
that flash is on Tuesday so it's gonna
be really busy for the next couple days
make sure you click that Bell to turn
alerts on so you don't miss any of the
videos congratulations to the latest DVD
giveaway winner Jojo moon please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details I'll
announce a new winner when I post that
next Game of Thrones video so while you
wait for everything click here for more
Season eight and you can click here for
that Justice League trailer that just
dropped thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight